it's a neurocognitive training program
that actually uses a neuro device that
monitors the brain of the student it's a
wearable neuro device and as a very very
good attention algorithm in it and it
allows the students to activate games by
being engaged we guide them to being in
their maximum state of attention and
then that activates certain elements it
activates the game but it also activates
certain elements in the game so they're
actually controlling the game by mind
alone and the game actually teaches them
a skill that supports executive function
it teaches them to reduce impulsive
behavior make good decisions
the program now is shipped globally in
ten different languages it is the number
one neurocognitive program for ADHD
students I actually created that genre
way back in the early 1990s boom what's
up everyone welcome to simulation I'm
your host Don sake and we are on-site at
the transformative technology conference
down in Palo Alto in California we are
very grateful for our partnership with
them this weekend at their conference we
are sitting down with a bunch of the
thought leaders at the conference we
have Peter freer joining us from for
your logic it's a pleasure to be here
thanks for coming on the show appreciate
it
I enjoyed I loved the transform of tech
conference I love the atmosphere they've
created in here yeah it's really nice to
be here and actually for your logic fits
perfectly into it and you know as we as
we talk about what you're doing with
your logic Neurosci burn etics wearables
that are not a a funny-looking like
Google glass tile had been the reason
why that didn't succeed just looks a
little too funny wasn't ready wasn't
quite there at the time that what people
weren't ready for it but the the we'll
get to we'll get to what you're building
I want to ask you about you first you
know who are you how did you
even end up caring about you know neuro
tech and wearable technology and mapping
the brain yeah how did that even happen
with your lecture it's a long story
I'm a former educator and when I started
teaching back in the mid-1980s I had
students who could attention and at that
time there was really no formal
diagnosis no formal description they
called it minimal brain dysfunction and
they eventually called it ADHD but I had
a math science physics computer
programming background from University
and I thought well I will make a program
that will fix these students so I said
about doing it working three jobs six
days a week
school teachers don't make much money
and I came out with in 1994 play
attention was the first company I
started and you can see that at play
attention calm it's a neuro cognitive
training program that actually uses a
neuro device that monitors the brain of
the student it's a wearable neuro device
the program now is shipped globally in
ten different languages it is the number
one neurocognitive program for ADHD
students I actually created that genre
way back in the early 1990s and I
actually got to work with some folks at
NASA because NASA was using neuro tech
to train astronauts to pay better
attention in states of hypo and hyper
arousal and we were fortunate enough to
adapt the technology NASA spin-off
magazine featured me a couple of times
and then we got patents based on our
enhancements to what they had been doing
but we were limited there just to that
space to the ADHD space by the way it
was tested by Tufts University School of
Medicine in three randomized controlled
studies and we knocked it out of the
park they're all published in three
peer-reviewed journals and our students
increased in attention executive
function behavioral control and academic
performance as well as social
performance as well too because that's a
area that they have but struggling for
most ADHD students we teach us about
play attention right play it and play it
and play attention which is like that
like
the title of the name there now with
play attention what were they doing
because there was a there's a hardware
component and a software component there
you had a game that they were playing
and you were monitoring their neural
signature okay so then what how was the
wearable that you made then able to
actually monitor things like attention
or executive function and also what was
the software like that they were yeah
that's the right question yeah the neuro
monitor that was used I developed to
wear on the arm and of course I was told
initially I wouldn't be able to do it
because the signals so small so I worked
on it for about three years and we
finally came up with something that has
a very very good attention algorithm in
it and it allows the students to
activate games by being engaged right we
guide them to being in their maximum
state of attention and then that
activates certain elements it activates
the game but it also activates certain
elements in the game so they're actually
controlling the game by mind alone and
the game actually teaches them a skill
that supports executive function it
teaches them to reduce impulsive
behavior make good decisions even
something as simple as finishing
homework we actually have the academic
bridge where they can work on homework
in real time and the attention monitor
is monitoring how much attention they're
paying to their homework and it alerts
them when it's not enough to get
homework done in a normal amount of time
and actually it's a teaching program so
once they've learned how to do it they
don't need us anymore right they get the
skillsets that they need and we've done
this you know Tufts the tough studies
were really kind of key in learning
about how this actually works I lectured
on this at the United Nations because I
had done work for the International
Atomic Energy Agency of the United
Nations to teach nuclear operators how
to pay better attention so what we do is
of course add that neuro component so
Tufts thought well it's nonsense you
don't need a neuro component brain
training is brain training as brain
training so in their tests
against us they pitted us against games
like Lumosity brain games that people
can play and then a non intervention
group
I think brain training is brain training
you don't need a neuro component so when
we put the neuro component in especially
among this population we had great
success when we were compared the brain
training group our group excelled in all
those areas I previously mentioned the
brain training group excelled in none
they had no increased ability in any of
those areas as a matter of fact they
required an average of 9 milligrams
increase in their medication just to
stay in school and that was about on the
same level as the non total non
intervention group so it tells you that
the neuro component having the person be
engaged is a critical component to
changing behavioral outcomes and
cognitive outcomes the fact that I can I
can pull your attention in and mandate
that to operate the game that you're
playing to learn a certain skill is
critical for you to make a change and
that we have found to be a key factor in
training da Vinci robotic surgeons
Olympic athletes we do all of this now
based on the fact that we've been doing
that type of training for years we also
can do it remotely so let's say you're
in San Francisco and I'm back in North
Carolina at our offices and you have my
armband
I can train you in real-time I could
train 20 people in real-time from across
the globe all with a single application
that we have now so we not only have
specialized in in training in that area
but also being able to do it remotely
for a wide population but that limited
us to that ADHD realm you know kind of a
neuro cognitive training element so we
moved out of that in 2005 I thought you
know there is no way that we're going to
be able to get this into a consumer
realm unless we have more than the body
based armband I'd like to use it in car
so I actually created a steering wheel
for Jaguar Land Rover and you could grab
the steering wheel and it would
monitor your engagement your neural
information was being distributed or
obtained through the steering wheel well
I got back to Detroit and the guys in
Detroit said we work gloves in the
wintertime what are you gonna do so I
had to come up with a new model a new
form factor and I watched a movie called
contact with Jodie Foster yes Carl Sagan
if your nerd yes you I've watched that
movie in an army time fell asleep woke
up at 3 o'clock in the morning and I
shipped my wife awake and I said I know
what I'm doing I know how to do this so
I devised an array series that would be
able to monitor the brain from a
distance so in effect we don't need
contact with the head any longer or the
body so I put it in a headrest and we
called a neuro bio monitor because
officially EEG requires attachment it
denotes that you have sensors attached
to the head and we don't we call the
neuro bio monitor and we're able to get
enough signal from the driver do you
determine drowsiness to determine
cognitive load so if they're trying to
text and drive and it becomes dangerous
we can tell them the car becomes
conscious then of the driver we've kind
of dubbed it at this point the conscious
car because it becomes aware of what
your state is and then assist you so
it's essentially passive nothing ever is
injected into the driver it just listens
like the microphones that we're wearing
listen to our voice this listens for
your brain signal but their passive
until such a time that you're having a
problem with getting too sleepy to drive
and then the car can alert you it will
vibrate your seat maybe what waft coffee
scent through the car or even tell you
right
you're too dry and drowsy to drive it's
time to pull off the road get some
coffee something like that so that it
becomes a safety feature in the vehicle
in autonomous driving which is coming up
it would also monitor the driver for
driver engagement because it's still
critical that you're not reading a book
and while the car is
driving because we've already seen some
extreme accidents happen under the
current situation with autonomous
vehicles let's talk about how the
technology works so how can you via a
wearable so tap into some of the nervous
system in the forearm or even like you
said without even a wearable the neuro
biofeedback how can you do that how does
that work so you have the nerves in your
body your nervous system runs from the
brain all the way down to the tips of
your toes
and it's all throughout your body you
probably didn't even know that you have
brain cells neurons in your gut you have
a secondary nervous system in your guide
people often said well I've got feeling
about that well not that that the
neurons there are ever going to write a
poem or a novel but they are it shows
that we have quite an active nervous
system and we found that if we tune the
electronics appropriately we can get it
through the body but we have to
eliminate things like muscle tension
another artifact heart rhythm that kind
of thing because those are very strong
elements to pick up a very faint signal
because when you look at neuro signal so
it's it's formed because the brain is
comprised of billions of cells called
neurons and the neurons have to talk to
each other to functionally they make
minor networks and major networks
throughout the brain so you have the
internet going on in your brain and when
they talk to each other they shoot a
neurotransmitter between the cells
either activates her or deactivates the
cell next to it right and that
neurotransmission in itself is so small
you can't measure one neuron it's just
way too tiny unless you stuck a
micro-fine
sensor probe down there Elan musk says
that's a good thing to do
and eventually we probably will do that
when they can make it convenient enough
to do but just the thought of sticking
wires into one's brain is kind of
repulsive to most people at this point
so right now we listen
to that signal by taking a mass of the
the neurons when they fire so whenever
you get an a brain signal it is always
the summation or aggregate of hundreds
of thousands if not millions of neurons
firing at one time because that produces
enough energy a field of energy that
goes through the cerebral spinal fluid
the meninges the dermis and if it pushes
or pulls on sensors on the top of the
end that's EEG it creates a field of
energy and so what the neuro bio monitor
is designed to do is to listen to a
field of energy and then parse it down
into constituent elements like various
brainwave frequencies is that making any
it is so continue though we're right
there where you just left off so if
you're if you if I'm using my my pillow
and my pillow is a neuro biofeedback
what is the tool would sorry what is the
item that you are using that is
collecting the neuro biofeedback what is
it oh so in this case we would use it in
the vehicles that we're using it in it's
a headrest so it's locating you'll never
see it it's in the headrest of you know
I get it now you know I'm carrying
around a headrest I was like what is
going on why do you have a car headrest
in here
interesting so they it so they're so
they're just driving and then what is
the what is what is located inside of
the headrest of the driver's seat what
is that thing that's there so there is
an array in there and this is what came
through the the contact movie when I
watched them use array of radio
telescope arrays a radio telescope to
monitor extraterrestrial signal signal
the hundreds of not millions of
light-years away we can actually see
faint signals so I thought well by using
an array and then tuning the array to
the human brain that we would be able to
collect enough signal to create
algorithms that interpret those signals
and
give us the state of the driver so we
did testing with Auto OEM alright and in
a simulator we were able to beat the
current system which is called a per
closed system per closed system is a
camera system that looks at how heavier
eyelids are getting and then to tries to
it sets an algorithm on it and says okay
you're this sleepy based on that of
course you're looking at an external
physical feature that is apparent well
after the fact that the brain has
already moved to that state so we can
look at it in real-time so we beat per
closed by 2 to 10 minutes 10 minutes was
our best two minutes was our worst
effort in determining drowsiness now we
also use something called the Karolinska
sleepiness survey and our scale
sleepiness scale which is a subjective
thing as you would be doing the testing
we would ask you at certain points how
sleepy do you feel scale of one tonight
and you would tell us on that scale the
per closed system got zero correlation
and we got eighty percent correlation
and so not only did we beat it in time
we also beat it in correlation to what
people subjectively felt about their
sleep now some people obviously don't
know they're getting drowsy and that's
why people fall asleep and go off the
road right they don't really know they
think they can beat it or they don't
really know yeah so we know we're on the
right track and we expect to be out in
vehicle by 2020 we've been at it for two
years with auto manufacturers and that
we expect it to be in as a safety
feature not too distant future oh my
gosh is the next seatbelt it is and it's
totally again totally passive we don't
inject anything into you there's no
radio wave going into your head we just
listen and it's a it's a key safety
feature some auto OEM don't want it oh
no array of how is it just listening to
the electrical activity sitting here so
there's a heavy amplification system
behind it with electronics that amplify
this
he tiny signal that comes from the head
so there's amplification that I can't
tell you the secret sauce yeah yeah
right but there is heavy amplification
and heavy filtering that has to go on so
that we can actually see what's
happening in real time but there is I
mean the signal that's there and
amplifying it yeah just like your
microphone does right here there's tiny
microphone is taking this the vibration
of the air coming from me and then
obviously amplifies that like crazy and
then it feeds it in wirelessly into the
camera it's very much like that
interesting yeah I I'm glad you gave
that analogy of the the next you know
this next seatbelt or the next that what
was at the Israeli car company that got
the the Auto assist for the lane
switches now in every single
manufacturer I think that they're almost
there at least so so now it's
interesting there seem to be this is a
this is an important place especially
because the transition to autonomous
isn't coming so so soon so there's
plenty of a runway probably maybe 10
years and then even after 10 like you
said they're still applications for
autonomous I got to be honest with the
year one of the first interviewers I've
ever ever spoken to that actually has a
real grasp of what that's like because
all the and I don't want to get myself
in too much hot water here but a lot of
the car companies are projecting that
it's around the corner and it's going to
be in the next couple of years and the
reality of the technology is that it's
just not there yeah and I think you're
right
8 to 10 years out we will have and cars
have to be interconnected there's gonna
be a lot of work that's done but
everybody wants to keep their stock up
so they say that they're around the
corner cork I just would not personally
I would not use it myself right now
totally and so then you'll still be
around even through the autonomous
vehicles monitoring the electrical
activity right now what can you get from
the electrical activity of the brain at
such a
at such a distance even though it's at
it's not that far
it's not an EEG it's it's not you're not
wearing the electrodes but there's this
array and the array is taking what is on
the surface of the brain amplifying it
and you're mostly collecting those big
neural activations like you were talking
about when a lot of the neural
infrastructure lights up and you're able
to get a big reading from something like
that so what we're looking at is
something that's been done for many many
years in the industry we look at the
brain data that are coming from the
person and then we interpret that and to
say it's that person drowsy is that
person angry is that person stressed is
that person paying attention and there
are algorithms written on those data and
we've created new ones and we'll keep
creating some but there already have
been there's been a lot of work in that
arena already the people have created
algorithms to interpret different things
and so that's creating art creating our
own from this is really the key so it's
not only the electronics but it's the
key to working in an auto situation
which is different than working a say in
your pillow on your on your bed we've
actually had a mattress company do that
and I'm not allowed to reveal who they
who that is right now but well they're
doing a similar like array and in a bet
we've done it for them oh and they
actually were at CES vikon they were at
CES a couple of years ago and they were
having races so you and your spouse or
your friend could jump in these beds and
then through an attention algorithm you
could race each other to see sleep yeah
so that was the whole idea here's an
interesting question for you is the is
is the is what the array is detecting
you're we're discussing these kind of
like bigger activations and these
algorithms that can detect if it's
happiness or if it's sadness or if it's
this dippers if it's the drowsiness etc
is is this a is the array sensing a if
the the drowsiness would be something
like a delta like a deep sleep
brainwave or even like a theta is like
getting kind of close to that as well
very late deeper meditative state versus
if they're at like a like a mid-range
beta like just like a faster wave then
are you are you getting that are you
getting there more wait are you getting
that kind of data yes yeah absolutely so
we can parse into respective bandwidths
Delta being the long slow rolling wave
that's usually dominant during sleep if
you have alpha spindles during Delta you
have REM sleep so you're dreaming theta
is right just prior to sleep as you
mentioned so we do that but we also we
have three tiers in Fourier logic one is
automotive so we do that in automotive
but the other one is consumer tack which
is one of the reasons we're here and
then the third is training so as I
previously mentioned we also train to
Vinci robotic surgeons Olympic athletes
things like that
so that they can attain better
performance because again three kit a
critical catalysts to causing prolonged
changes in the brain of the long-term
changes in the brain one key catalyst is
attention so we can create that through
the neuro monitoring right the second
one that you have to have is challenge
if I'm going to teach you something new
that's you're going to retain and create
the new neural networks responsible for
because we know these are catalysts we
actually know the molecular process
behind that it's called the kreb process
cyclic AMP response elements and binding
proteins so we know how the brain
actually goes about actually sending out
messenger RNA and saying here's this new
neural network that needs to happen so
we know the molecular structure and and
mechanism so what we do is take a look
at the macro how do we get them to
actually happen well one of the key
catalyst is attention the second one is
Chan
if I tell you something you already know
you nod your head you and I already know
but if I take you to the limits of your
knowledge base and push you just a
fraction further and I can keep your
attention while I'm doing that that's
challenge right and it forces you to go
just a step further yeah and we can
actually do that with the attention
level system of like the most profound
moments of existence is when you unlock
that new dimension of thinking the new
verse of - the new perception an
augmentation and perception is so
fascinating brilliantly said that's
exactly where we're pushing the envelope
right yeah to be able to draw people to
do that instead of for years you know
good golfer is probably one of the best
example a golfer will go out and hit a
bucket of balls doing the same thing
he's done for the last 20 years and he
goes and placing any goes my a-game
still stinks I don't play well because
I'm not engaged I do the same things I
do all the time neuro technology can
engage us and then with the proper type
of training and this is a term coined by
Anders Ericsson was University Central
Florida wrote a tome on on how we become
experts right so he knows exactly and
what the the technique is and he can
talk about it but we're the ones that
actually can actually make it happen in
in a neuro sense right so you have
attention and being pulling engaging the
person and then taking them to a state
of challenge state of challenge and you
can not only take them to the state of
challenge you about the material they're
learning but you can take them to a
state of channel of a challenge about
how much attention they're paying to the
new material does that make sense yep
okay and so the last leg of that tripod
is deliberate practice and the
deliberate practice model is under
Erikson being able to do it with
feedback so now the neuro tech is giving
you immediate fee
back about how engaged you are it's
giving you immediate feedback about your
challenge level now how do you show this
feedback so let's say that you're
playing one of our one of the ADHD games
we use is is called discriminatory
processing or even I think and another
good one to use here would be just
attention stamina to learn how to
prolong how to sustain and direct and
for a longer attentional event so during
that we give you a simple character you
push to the bottom of the ocean or your
attention level more attention you pay
you push the character down it needs
collecting treasure and various articles
small ways down there but we don't let
you stay there because if I let you stay
there you're on autopilot and become
disengaged after a while so every and
this is in the algorithm every little
while or so we challenge you to pay a
little bit more attention so there's the
attention challenge if you don't make it
right he starts floating the wrong way
and you know there's the immediate
feedback I've got to get a little bit
more attentive so then you if you can
catch it you push him back down so we're
increasing your attention to the task
and then secondarily if you don't make
it I can't do it it's too hard for me it
just takes you back to your last more
successful level but then it's got to
repeat in a cycle right I don't let you
stay there yeah yeah because we know
that human beings just produce so much
more when you give them that little
sense of challenge and that's it in its
most simplest sense but we then we give
you course material so if you're
learning a new skill like discriminatory
processing time on task
short-term memory working memory spatial
memory then we also increase the ante of
the challenge of those games so you're
getting the challenge for the tending to
the challenge level in the game so that
you're always pushed to your maximum but
never allowed to be overwhelmed and fail
because that's where people get
discouraged and then new neural networks
won't form so this was a key factor when
we developed all the neuro cognitive
training there's a lot of people have
said and I've there's a company that
just got a huge amount of money because
they're creating a little iPad game that
you can use and gyros and manipulate
down and
supposed to develop kilee interactive
life and I think it is yeah and the
ideas brilliant guys but they've kind of
isolated attention problems all to
attention and some processing problems
the problem with ADHD is that it's vast
and that is a problem of executive
function not only impulse control but
the ability to make good decisions the
ability to pay attention as is still a
factor all of these are in there and
there's far much more and they actually
have to have certain goals and certain
skill sets that they just don't have the
ability to finish tasks if you don't
teach these skills the shirt short-term
memory working memory spatial memory
even social cues if you don't teach them
the students don't arrive at them by
osmosis so it has to be part of the
curriculum that's when I discovered back
in the late 1980s and filed patents on
being able to do that integration with
neuro tech because no one had thought of
doing it everyone was just looking at
brainwave patterns and saying if we fix
these brainwave patterns person is fixed
it's nonsensical in a physical sense if
I'm trying to teach you something you
know teaching you you to improve your
brainwaves is not going to necessarily
improve your golf game or your
basketball game I have to get you out on
the court we have to give you the
challenge we have to look at how engaged
you are training your focus in general
though will slowly help in those if
you're good at it already it should make
you better but if I want to make you
really good and this is one of the
things we did by using the wearable
devices is that we can allow you now to
actually do the activity and we can
watch your brain processes as you do it
now is the wearable the consumer good it
is and so is that already available it's
only available right now in the play
attention games in the play tension so
when you when you order the game then
you're able to get the neurofeedback
wearable exactly and then and then the
again so there's the automotive
component there's the consumer good
component when you go through the
purchasing of the
as well and then what is the cost of the
of the game right now the games for a
full program for home use which is to
user licenses so you can use it with two
of your kids at home or your spouse or
yourself is 1795 and that is thousand
seven hundred that's the full course
though so if you are going to any Center
to get food rings all the games includes
all the games look who's all the games
okay and then and it includes a
neurofeedback neuro and it includes
totally free support for your life so
you get an executive function coach
person has a master's in education and
they actually evaluate your data at any
time you send in your data they do a
full evaluation it's no extra cost you
can have it for professional use for
$2,500 essentially and it's unlimited
use we don't recollect fees that way if
you went to a tutoring center to try to
get tutoring for problems cognitive
problems you would pay between three to
eight thousand dollars on the light side
people often take second mortgages on
their home to go through these processes
but you don't get as much out of it as
you do in the neuro tech program because
you don't have those extra things that
we've kind of combined in there so so I
want to do a couple power/power round
questions with you now what is again is
this when I'm wearing your neuro tech
device am i is is it right is it so
close to my central nervous system and
my central nervous system my brain is is
able to send that that electrical signal
is able to be detected from something
that's closer to my wrist that your
sensitivity is that high yeah this
equipment is sensitive down to one
hundred nano volts that's ten to the
minus nine novels that's really
sensitive yeah well an addition to that
it has to be coupled with incredible
filtering to get out all of the junk
that's between your head and this point
in your arm or me
even on your ankle if you're a golfer
interesting and then would you say that
then when you are focusing on the diver
and the divers going down in the game
and then the you can you can tell the as
soon as the focus leaves the diver the
diver starts going back up towards the
surface and so that's how this game is
is being played
yeah this process is very familiar very
familiar for me because of Vipassana
meditation where you just sit and you
observe your respiration through your
nostrils and observe and then your mind
wanders and then you go wow I can't
believe I just monkey minded for 10
minutes out and about and exactly and
you bring it back to your respiration so
it's it's interestingly training your
focus and in a similar way in that sense
and just observing just the diver
observing just the diver observing just
the diver making sure they go down it
was every just that not letting it go
elsewhere
so there's about a half second instead
of wandering for ten minutes
yeah there's maybe half second latency
between what's happening here and then
the visualization of those so the
training is like it's immediate
immediate because you see the
visualization of you losing attention
whereas with when your mind just wanders
I mean without without a cue you know
your eyes are just closed and you just
go off thinking all emails phone calls
meetings this go mom dad brother sister
it just goes off sex food drugs your
music it's just everywhere and so when
you have a visual cue like you said you
said half a second F second late that's
that's incredible then I can totally see
how that can also do the peak
performance stuff that you're talking
about that's huge that can really help
people Zone in to what they want well
the third the third leg of this tripod
is training so we actually have Lotus
app for people who want to meditate so
you sit in front of a lotus flower and
it's closed and then you hit a deep
meditative relaxed state much like
you're talking about by listening to
your breathing cycles I used to do that
a martial artist since I was 10 years
old
former professional fighter all of that
so having that ability to see the lotus
flower and then going through my
engagement to it my in that meditative
state you can open the lotus petal by
petal when I lose the state the petal
starts to close up that's pretty cool
too so you have this immediacy right in
front of you again see you can't lose it
for ten minutes you have this right in
front of you and you know where you have
to be so it cuts the time down yeah of
training and teaching yourself how to
how to do this it's very interesting
that's insightful and it's 2,500 years
ago we didn't have you know this is only
like you said 20 lesson 25 years old
interesting yeah I can't believe it's
also nuts to me that this is if you
would have told me I only made this
yesterday I would have been like yeah
it's because that that's really though
that's the earliest we could have gotten
that sensitivity but you're like 25
years ago and I'm like how is that what
no no we actually had to use helmet
modified helmets did in 94 was 94 is
helmets helmets yeah and today I started
in 2005 when did you start as a 2005 5
yeah part of I wouldn't have thought you
know 14 years ago that we could have
gotten that sensitivity but you know it
also doesn't make sense that we were
around them there I think there's a lot
of interesting yeah collaboration
explorations between between our
networks of neuroscientists and these
sort of peak performance experts the
ability to to get instantaneous
neurofeedback and then to be able to do
cognitive enhancing games is this
extremely important I think the good
thing I always talk about this but the
the peak of cognition is around this 23
ish 24 Sh
age range and so right when you're at
that age range it's you can you can
literally start telling yes sir sure
certain things pick up as though my
vocabulary gets stronger over
I can tell but it is also true that you
can't do your one hour of sleep night
and then go and be like ha ha ha the
next day stuff yeah so there's certain
things that if you if you do go and and
practice focusing on your attention on
something like meditation or these games
and there's so many applications what
are some of the future applications that
you look to that you're looking forward
to developing well we are working
forming a ton forming another company
that is going to work on communication
and how to one of the patents that I've
got that is pending right now is that if
we can monitor each other's neuro signal
without touching and then can
communicate it back and forth we have
this ability for nonverbal communication
the groundwork so that is underway
but in a practical sense even right now
since we have developed a decent
drowsiness algorithm we've reversed it
so then you know when you were talking
about your mind just being so racing at
night when I'm lying and this happens to
everyone I'm trying to go to sleep yet
I'm thinking about all the things that
occur during the day then my mind
wanders for that from home and then they
come back and all the things I have to
do tomorrow and these lists start
forming and then I'm not asleep at all
and I have a very difficult time telling
this computer to to shut down so we've
created the sleepy series so that we put
the drowsiness detection in Reverse so
we actually push you into a state of
drowsiness how can I give you that state
so we actually have one called the
sleepy Beach yeah and sleepy Beach is
just this 3d beach scene you can look at
on your cell phone
mmm and the Sun's up in the sky and so
when you start to to breathe deeply and
relax and move your mind away from
thought you'll start to make the sunset
and then the star start to come up and
you'll be able to raise the moon and we
actually have a demo of melatonin
it is your your actually teaching your
brain to cooperate I mean this is one of
them gonna lecture here tomorrow or not
lecture I'm going to speak tomorrow and
we'll demo a little bit tomorrow too
during the presentation but the idea is
that the brain is is an organ of
reduction all of this all of this
interaction between us all of the people
around us is reduced in the brain to the
random firing of neurons it's there
that's our inner universe yet we have no
control over any of it yeah right we
don't know how to master this thing this
our core tool we have no idea how to
master so we try these physical
techniques we'll try meditation then we
find out cache I just wandered off for
tennis that was a waste then I get back
I'll go for a couple more minutes and I
wander for five and they come back so
now we are giving people the tool they
actually need to train this to be one of
the most powerful assets they'll ever
possess in their life and one of the
points tomorrow is going to be a quiet
revolution that I'm going to talk about
but AARP surveyed I think close to 50 or
60,000 of its members and sat out of
everything that you want what is most
important to you and of course you would
think wealth I got to have money wasn't
that health health wasn't that no not
cognition cognition keeping my mind
sharp art was the number one priority
because you can have all the money in
the world but you've watched your
friends dissolved to Alzheimer's they
have all the money they want it's not
helping you can have health but then
your mind is going so it's almost
related but we'll separate it right but
if my mind stays sharp yeah I can make
good decisions and I can live a happy
life in that like 15 year-old
homeostatic capacity of the of the mind
throughout our life that would be
fantastic
I wanted this it does it almost seem as
though you're giving people free will
we can't give them something that's
already there so you know what we're
giving them the ability to do is to use
this tool to its maximum potential for
each individual that's different you're
already really insightful you've been
you've done a lot I can tell by the way
that you're interacting with me you know
a lot about what we're talking about and
that's uncommon but you're in this tech
world you have experienced a lot but now
you know my goal and passion has been to
make this thing functional for everyone
and make neuro tech functional but in a
car it functions one way for training it
functions another for consumer products
to help me go to sleep you know at night
it's very practical but we need to have
you know this is the time where we can
control this thing this is a time where
as your cognition is peaking around that
2324 that you have the ability to play
these cognitive enhancing games and
retain more of your focus over time that
you can offset the onset of nerd
generation yeah yeah this is very
fascinating stuff I'm glad we had the
chance to sit down and explore it in a
lot of it's nuanced is there something
else about for your logic that is
important to know about it are you well
I'll let you answer that question I'm
curious about the about the the sort of
the the neuro cybernetics that you were
discussing at the beginning as well you
know is there a way that what you're
understanding with the algorithms that
you have put together that now somebody
else can but you can open source some of
that and someone else can potentially be
able to you know understand the what's
going on with brain activity and make
something that helps in a different area
or field so it's like kind of you know
you're making the knowledge map
knowledge graph well I think so in a way
it's possible to do but in a way we we
hold patents on the ability to take it
from the body
and at patents pending on the
non-contact use but we will open that up
eventually to let people have full use
of it because that's where it's going to
produce the best effects yeah long term
but I've got a you have probably a bunch
of entrepreneurs that listen to your
show right so I want to make certain I
tell everybody this I was told that I
couldn't do this I was told by as a
matter of fact there is a venture
company here it's jazz ventures I think
oh yeah yeah
Jesse we don't think you can do it you
know we don't think you can do what
you're saying you're doing yet we've
already gotten awards for and we're in
one of the top 10 startups to the LA
Auto Show right now so we'll be down
there at the end of this month we also
have been working solidly with tier ones
and we're already doing it I actually
had fellow set CES neuroscientists come
down and sit in in a sofa with the
headrests behind them they start
controlling the computer screen in front
of them and I had one of the most the
funniest response is one neuroscientist
likes amigas so where the switches let
me see your hands so I open my hands I
said what are you talking about yes this
is magic you can't do it I said you're
doing it right now you're controlling I
can see that but you have a switch and
he stands up and he flips up the sofa
cushion and these where's the switch I
said there is no switch you're doing
this right now you can't do it I said
but we are doing it yeah so well I think
if you are familiar with how I was the
fellow that wrote 2001 yeah yeah
yeah so one of his tenants was new
science and the ability to do things
differently we often look like magic it
does it does and there's gonna be lots
of naysayers and it's important to to
push through you know and I think a lot
of people have traumatic stress around
new science as well because like that
like their nose and stuff like that yeah
you know so [ __ ] like that comes up and
then and then people are like are like
who do I trust and so that's that's why
I think another reason
why it happens but we got a we have to
have open-mindedness but also just
enough like neuroticism to be able to
really tap into the energy of the other
person and be like is this actually you
know real but you also have to have
enough discipline in science to dig into
the the deepest understand a good point
well and we don't do any of our own
evaluation or analysis on data that are
monitored or acquired by third parties
so if an OEM or a Tier one we don't we
don't do that
because then if we did it and we did
that initially on one or two occasions
we send it back the analysis and it was
really good and they go well you make it
you can say anything and that's true so
a certain amount of skepticism is very
very healthy so we sent it off to
university Connecticut Medical School
different places that could evaluate
Samsung for example and they evaluated
and given you that's where at least when
I told you about yeah these reports came
from outside independent third parties
I'm not you know telling you I would do
that because you know obviously just
like Thoreau knows you could come up
with anything and keep it looking
shining because you're producing your
own results but we went outside and
that's I think is their o absolute key
to this process to building trust was
there something else on the way out that
you thought I think is important of
course on the entrepreneurial push that
was a huge point is going execute and
don't let people say you can't do it yet
go and execute you have to have the
right people around you you have people
that will support you whether it's a
venture your lawyers your family have
people that will definitely support you
and I had been in the field since the
mid-1980s and when I said well I'm going
to try to do this through the body I was
told by a neuroscientist at Northwestern
University he said I don't know if you
can do it why would you want to we can
already get it from the head that's like
but you're missing the point it's never
going to break into consumer use if we
keep it on the head
and he goes all yeah you're right about
that well I don't know if you could do
it if you can I want one yeah
and that's how that all you know how we
we laughed about it and we left it like
that and of course we did create it and
it has the correlates to EEG we don't
call it an EEG monitor we have to call
it a neuro monitor making me really want
to play the games I really want to play
them so that we can do yeah all set up
and let you sit in front of the headrest
and you can have at it let's do it it's
pretty good let's do it let's do that
and then I would love to for the people
that come into our studio that are
venture capitalists or neuro scientists
or other prominent folks in the Bay it
would be really good for us to ii ii ii
ii have a wearable in in studio so that
they can play the game of like the
deep-sea diver and and they can actually
see okay let me alright I'll start
thinking about you know my girlfriend oh
it's going up you know so if they can
actually see and play with it to see if
and that's another way you get an
experiential wisdom of this is truth
because I'm experiencing this as truth
otherwise it wouldn't be able to
fluctuate the way that you're describing
it it would have trouble with that if it
wasn't yeah right right that you can see
and I'll be demoing that the trans tech
conference tomorrow at I think it's a
little after 2:00 in the afternoon I'll
be demonstrating it on the big stage
pull someone right out of the audience
and have them control the auto simulator
right on the screen yeah in real-time
and then I'll distract them yeah and
you'll see what happens so that you can
see it can be done in real-time and
we've been able to go quite a distance
with it and we continue to improve the
hardware because we want to get more
detail of audience to distract them
because then they don't know then they
know that it's not you picking a certain
time to distract them oh yeah good yeah
we can do that that's not a problem yeah
that's usually all you have to do is ask
him one or two silly questions that
they're listening to them
drop it out there yeah so yeah I'm
making the hardware better I'm excited
to actually see the you have the
hardware as well okay cool this has been
a lot of fun yeah thank you so much
questions yeah and at this yeah and this
rodeo before I love people it's it's
like you were saying before we started
it's just such an honor to be able to do
this work so Peter for you what a
pleasure yeah thank you so much I'm
appreciated on the show and teaching us
about for your logic so everyone thank
you for tuning in thank you for checking
this episode out give us a shout out in
the comments below let us know your
thoughts we'd love to hear from you
check out the for your logic links in
the bio also check out transformative
technology conference and go and build
the future go and manifest the future
and build it execute much love everyone
thank you
[Music]